in the last few days Sam Altman the CEO
of openai has publicly stated how much
money he expects the company to make and
how he intends to distribute it many
people will assume he is bluffing but I
think GT4 shows that he's not this video
will cover his plans his predictions of
massive inequality and open ai's new
paper on job impacts together with just
released studies that back it all up but
let's start with money this week in the
New York Times he said that his Grand
idea is that openai will capture much of
the world's wealth through the creation
of AGI and then redistribute this wealth
to the people and yes he mentioned
several figures a hundred billion
dollars one trillion even a hundred
trillion dollars if openai make even a
fraction of these figures Sam Altman
will become one of the most important
people on the planet that's not to say
that he would become that rich The Wall
Street Journal this week reported that
he has no direct Financial stake in the
business but deciding where trillions of
dollars of wealth go does make you
incredibly powerful so where does he
want all the money to go well he seems
to have two main ideas plus a third one
that I'll touch on at the end his first
idea is Ubi or Universal basic income we
also have funded the largest and most
comprehensive Universal basic income
study as sponsored by open Ai and I
think it's like an area we should just
be be looking into how exactly would
that work well he laid out his theory in
this blog post and he began it with this
he says he's reminded every day about
the magnitude of socioeconomic change
that is coming sooner than most people
believe he said that the price of many
kinds of Labor which drives the costs of
goods and services will fall towards
zero once sufficiently powerful AI joins
the workforce he said that that was
great for people buying products but not
so much for those working to earn a wage
so where would their money come from he
proposed something called the American
Equity Fund it would be capitalized by
taxing companies that were above a
certain valuation 2.5 percent of their
market value each year and it would also
be funded by taxing 2.5 percent of the
value of all privately held Land by his
calculation that will be worth around 13
500 in about twenty Thirty and he said
that that money would have much greater
purchasing power than it does now
because technology would have greatly
reduced the cost of goods and services
it does raise the question for me though
about those countries that aren't the
home of massive AI companies where are
they going to get the wealth from on Lex
Friedman's podcast he admitted it wasn't
a full solution I think it is a
component of something we should pursue
it is not a full solution I think people
work for lots of reasons besides money
he thinks much more will be needed
because the cost of intelligence could
fall to almost zero my basic model of
the next decade is that the marginal
cost of intelligence and the marginal
cost of energy are going to Trend
rapidly towards zero like surprisingly
far so what is his other main idea
simply use the money to fund science are
you planning to take the proceeds that
presumably you're presuming you're going
to make some day and you're going to
give them back to society I mean is that
yeah whether we do that just by like
saying here's cash for everyone totally
possible or whether we do that by saying
like gonna like invest all of this in a
non-profit that does a bunch of science
because scientific progress is how we
all make progress unsure but yeah we
would like to operate for for the good
of society even with these two ideas he
admits there's still a big problem as he
put it recently he sees a lot of people
getting very rich in the short to medium
term but others might not fare as well
if it is as divergent as I think it
could be for like some people doing
incredibly well and others not I think
Society just won't tolerate it this time
samuelman isn't the only one making
predictions open AI itself released this
paper around 10 days ago it calculated
that with access to a large language
model about 15 of all work tasks in the
US could be completed significantly
faster at the same level of quality but
crucially when incorporating software
and tooling built on top of llms this
share increases to around 50 percent of
all tasks that is a colossal impact For
Better or Worse just with gpd4 plus
software on page 17 of the paper it had
this table which I think captures a lot
of the interesting analysis let me
briefly explain what it shows we have a
column of example occupations in the
middle and the the education that is
required for each of them and the job
preparation but the numbers on the right
are where it gets interesting these are
the percentages of exposure graded Alpha
Beta And Zeta the human assessment of
exposure is titled H and the M is for
the machine assessment they actually got
gpt4 to do an assessment too notice that
for the most part gbt4 agrees with the
human assessors so what are these three
grades Alpha is the proportion of tasks
in these occupations affected by current
language models alone without any
further advances or Integrations beta
represents the percentage of tasks
exposed in a realistic scenario of
language models plus a bit of software
integration and a few advances you could
think of it as their median prediction
finally Zeta is a bit like their most
extreme scenario with full adoption of
software plus advances of llms by the
way we're not talking gc5 here or text
video just basic software integration
like a longer context window or text to
image the trend that immediately stuck
out for me was how when you go up the
educational levels and these salary
ranges the effects of these large
language models on task exposure goes up
and up and up until you reach master's
degree or higher levels then it seems to
dip down a little maybe this is why Sam
Altman predicted inequality the people
on the very Cutting Edge of science
would still get paid well probably
better than ever but there may be a
further hollowing out of the middle
class with working class occupations
left largely untouched the paper also
touches on why so few people might be
currently focused on language models I
don't know about you but have you
noticed that feeling where it seems to
be us being super interested in this
technology with most people not being
that interested well here might be one
reason why currently only three percent
of U.S workers have over half of their
tasks exposed to llms but that's only
when considering existing language and
code capabilities without additional
software or modalities so not that many
people are seeing a massive change in
their work but it says that when we
account for other generative models and
complementary Technologies are human
estimates indicate that up to 49 of
workers could have half or more of their
tasks exposed to llms whether this means
doubling the amount of work done or
halving the number of workers doing it
I'll talk more about later in the video
but maybe this was the dramatic economic
impact that Ilya satsukver once
predicted on Lex Friedman what do you
think is the bar for impressing us do
you think that bar will continuously be
moved definitely I think when you start
to see really dramatic economic impact
that's when I think that's in some sense
the next barrier because right now if
you think about the work in AI it's
really confusing it's really hard to
know what to make of all these advances
the paper also points out that the
growing economic effect of llms is
expected to persist and increase even if
we hold the development of new
capabilities today they refer to recent
study bodies revealing the potential of
llms to program and control other
digital tools such as apis search
engines and even other generative AI
systems in my previous video on the
self-improvement in GT4 I mentioned
hugging GPT but I am doing a lot of
research on the new Microsoft Jarvis
model and auto gbt I'm hoping to bring
to you soon but interestingly there were
some tasks that neither Gypsy 4 nor the
human assessors could quite agree on in
terms of the impact that llms would have
even gpd4 couldn't quite figure out if
meetings and negotiations would carry on
or to what extent counseling or other
jobs that involve empathy would be
affected and the paper concludes with
this the power of relatively simple user
interface improvements on top of models
like Gypsy 4 was evident in the rollout
of chat GPT wherein versions of the
underlying language model had been
previously available via API usage
skyrocketed after the release of the
chat GPT internet
it's a great Point once these models are
made easy to use that could change
everything the paper then picks up on a
particular survey that shows worker
adoption of llms here is the survey with
the rather dramatic headline of one in
four companies have already replaced
workers with Chachi BT I don't think
that assertion is fully backed up by the
evidence but they did survey 1 000 U.S
Business Leaders and there were some
interesting findings on the question of
replacing workers it says that when
asked if Chaturbate will lead to any
workers being laid off by the end of
2023 33 of Business Leaders say
definitely while 26 say probably others
are a bit more optimistic Goldman Sachs
said this this economic analysis was
published only a few days ago and they
say about seven percent of workers will
be fully displaced over the next 10
years but that most are able to find new
employment in only slightly less
productive positions they also predicted
that generative AI will raise overall
labor productivity growth by around 1.5
percentage points per year which
effectively doubles the rate going back
to Sam Altman last week he was asked
about this augmentation versus
replacement question so in terms of
really replace jobs is that a worry for
you it is uh I'm trying to think of like
a big category that I believe can be
massively impacted I guess I would say
customer service is a category that I
could see there are just way fewer jobs
relatively soon I'm not even certain
about that but I could believe it
whatever call center employees are doing
now I found that last comment on call
Center's quite interesting given that
the gc4 technical report talked about
using language models for upskilling in
call centers so does this mean immense
productivity in the short term but
replacement in the long term a couple
days ago Sam Altman put it like this I
always try to be honest and say in the
very long term I don't know what's going
to happen here and no one does and I I'd
like to at least acknowledge that in the
short term it certainly seems like there
was a huge overhang of the amount of
output the world 1 and if people are way
more effective they're just doing way
more we've seen this first with codeine
and people that got Early Access to
co-pilot reported this and now that the
tools are much better people report it
even more yep but we're now in this sort
of gpt4 era seen it in all sorts of
other jobs as as well where you give
people better tools and they just do
more stuff better stuff the productivity
point is backed up by experiments like
this when developers were split into two
groups half that used openai's co-pilot
and half that didn't not only did more
of those who use copilot finish 78 to 70
they finished in less than half the time
this paper from a few weeks ago shows
that when white collar professionals
were given a language model like chatbt
the time they took to do writing tasks
dropped massively compared to the
control group you can see that they took
less than 20 minutes versus almost 30.
and when the assisted group and control
group were blindly graded you can see
that the mean grade was higher for those
who use the language models but surely
if productivity goes up that means
higher wages for those jobs well not
necessarily a couple of days ago Sam
Altman laid out how it might be more
efficient to use one worker to do the
tasks of two or three there's a huge
cost premium on work that has to be
split across two people there's the
communication overhead there's the the
miscommunication there's everything else
and if you can make one person twice as
productive you don't do as much as two
people could do maybe you do as much as
three and a half or four people could do
and for many kinds of tasks but is there
anything that might slow this economic
impact down I think there might be a few
things starting with politics this
survey from Youth Of America was
released only three days ago and while I
think it is a somewhat leading question
it does show that over 69 of Americans
would support a six-month pause on some
kinds of AI development and if we see
dramatic negative economic impact I
expect that figure would go higher
politicians would then be in
incentivized to slow down tax and or
regulate AI development indeed two days
ago President Biden tweeted this when it
comes to AI we must both support
responsible Innovation and ensure
appropriate guard rails and also don't
forget if you live in a country where
English is not the main spoken language
gpt4 isn't as good notice that in many
languages found in India GT4 is worse
performing than the previous model GPT
3.5 is in English this is just one
reason why Goldman Sachs predicted
different levels of Automation in
different countries the next Factor
could be cultural pushback when Levi's
wanted to test AI generated clothing
models and they said their reason was to
increase diversity that announcement was
met with backlash they then had to back
down slightly and say that they're not
replacing the job of any model if people
vote with their wallets for human-made
goods and services that could have a
massive impact and there is another big
factor people seem to intrinsic quickly
prefer human-made output to machine
generated output this piece came out
recently from wired and in it they test
the brain chemical reaction to
human-made Art and computer made art
these were the same pictures it's just
that sometimes people were told they
were made by humans and other times they
were told they were made by computers it
says a clear winner emerged people not
only claimed to prefer the identical
human made pictures their brain's
pleasure sensors actually lit up more
brightly so human goods and services may
have the edge simply by virtue of being
made by humans but I want to end the
video where I began it with samuelman's
piece in the New York Times some of you
may have noticed that I said Sam Altman
had a third idea of how to distribute
the wealth that I would mention at the
end well he admitted if AGI does create
all that wealth he is not sure how the
company will redistribute it money could
mean something very different in this
new world but what's the idea he said I
I feel like the AGI can help with that
maybe GPT 5 will decide where the money
made using Gypsy 5 will go thank you so
much for watching to the end and have a
wonderful day